hi
my name is iman turia i'm a research
fellow in biotech i am an assistant
research professor in department of
surgery at tulane university
thank you for joining me today as i
share the findings of loving markers for
predicting malignancy into our
individuals this study offers a better
modality for cancer detection that's
more inclusive and fats all racial
groups
thyroid cancer is a common type of
endocrine malignancy
its incidence has been steadily
increasing in many regions of the world
the vast majority of thyroid tumors
arise from thyroid follicular epithelial
cells where three to five percent of
cancers originate from parafollicular
cells
the flickering cell derived cancers are
further subdivided into three categories
will differentiated papillary inflicted
carcinomas poorly differentiated
carcinomas and anaplastic or
undifferentiated carcinoma
follicular adenoma is a benign tumor
that may serve
as a precursor for some follicular
carcinomas
in patients presenting with thyroid
neutrons the clinically challenged is to
accurately and rapidly identify those
new joules that harbor cancer
similar to other cancer types thyroid
cancer initiation and progression occurs
through gradual accumulation of various
genetic and epigenetic filtrations
this includes somatic mutations and
microrna in the circulation
thyroid cancer represents a type of
nepalese in which the critical genes are
frequently mutated via two destinative
molecular mechanisms point mutation of
particular genes or chromosomal
rearrangements at particular size
fine needle respiration is used to
evaluate thyroid neutrals and remains in
the worldwide gold standard for workup
fine needle exploration results are
useful for stratifying malignancy risk
however only looking at the
cytopathology is a challenging in some
cases and further molecular tests are
proceeded such as mutation screening and
microorganic suppression analysis
these tests are essential to provide key
information for counseling patients in
determining the appropriateness of
surgery
the minority population in the us
accounts for 27.6
of the population so looking into the
seed database we found out population
with african-american descent had the
least incidence rate however they had
the worst five-year survival
highlighting the possibility of being
unreported or under-diagnosed
here at too late on analyzing 263
patients at tulin hospital who had more
regular diagnostic tests and underwent
surgical removal of the neutral
we found out through our clinical
practice that 50 to 67 percent
who were misdiagnosed
are non-white
leading to unnecessary surgeries and
complications or two-step surgical
management thus highlighting the urgent
need to investigate the possibility of
the concept that
not all tests fit all
therefore we aim to identify and
validate a microrna signature across
racial groups to diagnose cancer in
patients presenting with thyroid
neutrals
this is to test that if african
americans asians and hispanics require
different molecular biomarkers than
white non-hispanics
in addition using both rna and microrna
transcriptomic data we aimed to identify
the driver mechanisms of thyroid tumor
genesis in each race using the public
repositories tcga
database our analysis included nine
steps we downloaded the required data
for each racial group separately black
asian hispanic and white non-hispanic
then we did exploratory analysis to
visualize the variance among the data
samples boxoplots were first generated
to represent the sum of all genes within
each sample then transfer component
analysis or pca was performed in four
racial subgroups to look at the
subgrouping pattern of cancer and
controls and detect outliers among the
samples
then using the microrna sequencing data
comparative analysis was performed
within each racial strata to compare
between cancer versus non-cancer samples
by running the differential expression
pipeline
look to pounds per million of the data
was used and hr method was applied
significance was set if the voltage
change exceeds a plus or minus one and
adjusted p-value below 0.05 and now
regulated and up-regulated genes were
visualizing these four types of plots
volcano plot venn diagram offset plot
and cluster analysis
word d2 linkage and equating distance
measures were used in the hierarchical
clustering analysis
in step 4 we perform the supervised
machine learning technique and
evaluation matrix to construct a model
for predicting malignancy in thyroid
neutrals the session tree for
classification was employed which
yielded triple microrna biomarkers with
the best discriminator ability for
clinical application we generated the
diagnostic nomogram to visualize the
results of logistic regression a risk
score was generated from beta
coefficient of logistic regression model
and evaluated by receiver operator
characteristic curve or rock curve
analysis
production performance was compared to
the current modicular microrna panel
that's currently used in the clinic
for validation
stratified analysis of the tcge data by
demographic and pathological
characteristics including age sex
disease stage and histopathological
variants were reformed to compare the
performance of the model in each state
the expression pattern of the final
three micro rnas were also investigated
in other independent data sets in the
gene expression omnipost database for
external validation
furthermore we carried out function
enrichment analysis to unleash the
biological context of the three
micrornas which fits all the racial
groups
on the other hand to identify the driver
mechanisms specific for thyroid cancer
in each race we performed rna sequencing
analysis we concatenated log normalized
the rna and micron in the expression
matrices together
intersected the differentially expressed
genes and differentially expressed
micrornas with gene targets identified
from production tools and experimentally
validated databases
then the final lasts were integrated to
build a microrna gene network
next to analyze the tumor
microenvironment we assess the tumor
purity and the composition of immune
cell infiltration using three software
estimate cyber sword and micro
environment cell population counter
methods
next upstream regulatory network was
constructed through analysis of the
transcription factor targets derived
from the jasper and chepsic database
and kinase enrichment analysis was
performed using the x2k online database
function enrichment analysis for the up
and down regulated genes and
microorganisms were explored for each
racial group
and this to identify the driving
pathways and gene ontology annotation is
specific for each cohort
non-secretomic signature of 495 thyroid
cancer and 59 non-cancer tissue samples
were retrieved from the tcga database
in summary to over 2500 micrornas
and over 20 thousands messenger rnas and
long non-coding ironies from rnesic and
microorganisms were included clinical
pathological and medical information
were obtained from the sea bioportal of
cancer genomic and fiber browse
to gain insight about the data set as a
whole we perform a dimensionality
reduction using a principal component
analysis for each racial groups we
reduced the data of all samples into two
dimensions that best represent our data
in the four pca plot there was good
separation between cancer and control
samples with very few overlap in the
white non-hispanic group chords
volcano plots was performed to identify
differentially suppressed micrornas in
each racial group the plot is showing
the log to fold the change along the
x-axis and negative log 10 of the
adjusted p-value along the y-axis each
dot represents 1 micron in e at the
cutoff of absolute value of log fold at
1 and q below 0.05 significant genes are
defined in blue for down regulated and
bred for upregulated micro rnas
the tl significant 26 microns in black
28 in asians 29 in hispanics and 81 in
white non-hispanics as demonstrated in
the venn diagram intersection between
the four racial groups showed common 11
micrornas that were significantly
deregulated 10 were overexpressed and
the last one was down regulated
currently the standard of care relies on
11 microrna panels
used to distinguish between malignant
and benign thyroid neutrons
as demonstrated in the first horizontal
bar
in the two blue boxes that enclose seven
and four micrornas these are our 11
microns that are consistently
deregulated in all racial groups from
the tcga data
as marked by the yellow arrow only four
micro rnas of these existed in the
currently used molecular testing
some other micrornas don't have a rule
at all in any of the races
this heat map shows the expression level
of micro rnas across racial groups the
new panel of 11 micrornas one of them
were downregulated in blue and all
others were upregulated
on the other hand the old banil included
11 micrornas
four micronies were in common with our
new panel five of them did not show
significance in one or more of the
racial groups highlighting its low
potential to have good diagnostic
performance for all thyroid cancer
patients especially non-white patients
in the hierarchical clustering analysis
the algorithm detects closest objects
with similar pattern and linked them
together in the left photo our data
driven clusters showed that control
samples in orange were assigned together
having less distance between the samples
and forms distant cluster from cancer
patients unlike the old panel in the
right normal tissues were split across
different clusters
predictive model using decision tree
three microrna biomarkers were revealed
to be the best discriminator for
malignancy the session tree blot has
nodes connected by edges the best
classifier feature is at the root node
at the top which was microrna 34a
the height of this decision tree is
three and the bottom most level we have
the leaf nodes that hold the output
label
cancer or normal
with the combination of two other
micrornas 144 and 146 p at a cutoff
around fivefold change we had the best
diagnostic ability
next linguistic regress nomogram was
generated using the demographic
characteristics at the time of
presentation it takes a pressure profile
of the three micro rnas
it consists of several horizontal lines
marked off to scale
for each of the six parameters it gives
a point score
their sum predicted the risk of
malignancy in patients with thyroid
individuals
so here in this example this 60 years
old white non-hispanic male patient have
285 total points which is equivalent to
81.6
risk of malignancy
so to calculate the cumulative genetic
risk of cancer a rescue score was
generated using the three micro rnas
multivariate logistic regression
analysis performed in the beta
coefficients of the regression model was
used for imputation and using the
formula of the sum of the product of
microorganic suppression and its beta
coefficient for each sample
receiver operator characteristic curve
analysis was used to describe the
diagnostic ability of our new microrna
risk score and the accuracy of the
currently used microrna panel the closer
the curve
towards the upper left corner the better
the production ability of the diagnostic
index is
as demonstrated here the area under the
curve or auc of our generated risk score
shows a perfect production ability with
94 sensitivity and 98 specificity
while the old banner had poor productive
value to discriminate between malignant
and benign jewels
on the right
colonel dennis density blood shows
higher range of scores in cancer samples
compared to normal samples
to test its efficiency
at different disease conditions
iteration of analysis using data split
by sex age subtype stage etc the ability
of the microrna risk score to accurately
predict malignancy was assessed using
the concordance c statistic
here as we can see the risk score showed
excellent discrimination in all
conditions of patients
we analyzed two other datasets and we
had
similar results for micrornas 34 and
146b
were upregulated in cancer
while 144
were downregulated compared to controls
in the first experiment five beard
samples tissue samples of the pillar
thyroid carcinoma and non-cancer tissues
of the same individuals were analyzed
and using the same formula risk score
was estimated from the three micro rnas
similar to our primary findings high
score was associated with malignancy
in the other experiment eight pairs of
tissue samples were analyzed yielded
similar results
the same three markers are frequently
deregulated in other cancers as well
enrichment analysis revealed significant
enrollments of microorganism 34 in
particular in thyroid cancer and as
shown in redbox
and it was involved
in other cancer types in blue boxes
they were enriched in essential cancer
related pathways as adrens junction
b53 signaling pathway and cell cycle
pathway
microrna microarrays targets 16 genes
within thyroid cancer kick pathway
at different stages of thyroid
carcinogenesis from normal to ptc from
normal to adenoma to follicular thyroid
cancer and to undifferentiated carcinoma
thus highlighting the rule in cancer
development at different subtypes of
thyroid cancer
the top most significant genotology
terms were related to cell cycle
response to strats protein assembly
chromatin organization and cell death
all these processes are closely related
to thyroid cancer tumor genesis in the
literature
other molecular function terms were
related to cytoskeleton and methylation
to construct a gene microarticulatory
network rna-seq for each race was
performed through which the
differentially expressed genes were
defined
here this venn diagram shows the
differentially expressed genes in each
racial group
intersection demonstrated a common 609
genes that are deregulated in all
cohorts
co-expression analysis was performed for
each racial groups
those bears with correlation coefficient
of less than minus 0.5
were selected
gene targets were identified from
multiple well-annotated databases and
results were intersected with the
correlated bears
a final of 73 microrna aging target
interactions were further explored
regarding the tumor microenvironment
we used estimate software
it's a tool to calculate the fraction of
tumor cells in clinical tumor samples
using the next generation sequencing
data so we used the tcga data and we
found no significant difference in the
distribution and comparisons of stromal
and immune scores between different
racial groups
distribution and comparisons of a strum
and immune scores among different tumor
stages differentiation grades metastasis
histological subtypes and recurrence
also showed no significant difference as
well
regarding quantification of the exact
infiltrating immune cells we use two
softwares
cybersort and mcp counter methods
and cybersort tool was used to estimate
and distinguish 22 commonly infiltrating
immune cells in thyroid cancer patients
with different rays
while microenvironment cell population
counter methods quantify the absolute
abundance of eight immune and two
stromal cell populations in nutritionist
tissues from using gene expression data
strong sucratomic provides the thyroid
cancer samples will use to infer tumor
cellularity as well as different
infiltrating normal cells
we found out that must the cell
activated immune cell
was significantly higher in white
non-hispanic population than white
hispanics
so identify the driving mechanism for
each racial groups
microrna and gene set enrichment
analysis was performed
cake pathway analysis showed three
common pathways in wretched for the four
groups and this includes transcreptional
misregulation in cancer
and extracellular matrix receptor
interaction
in black population differentially
expressed genes and differentiate
suppressed micrornas were enriched in
axon guidance and regional metaphors
which is similar to the literature
asian population
genes were more related to several
autoimmune disorders
and immune related pathways
while in hispanics p53 signaling pathway
was significant
the well-known pathway is related to
braf mutation
as cmp
pi 3k act or map signaling pathways were
enriched in white non-hispanic dataset
transcription factor targets were
explored based on the gene expression
data we found 89 transacreption
factories to be in ratchet the top 20
are shown
some of the genes like foxy1 and geta2
can target hundreds of differentially
expressed genes
two of the significantly enriched
transcription factor list were
differentially expressed in our cohorts
chipseek enrichment analysis prioritized
transcription factors that most likely
to regulate the observability changes in
messenger rna suppression in each race
some of these were up or down regulated
in our thyroid cancer samples
kinase enrichment analysis was performed
to prioritize protein kinase is known to
phosphorylate substrates within the
subnetwork of transcription factors and
the connecting proteins
as shown here the top kinesis that are
enriched using the specific
differentially expressed genes of each
group
intersecting the significant kinase list
with the corresponding differentially
expressed genes in each rays
defined the upregulated kinases within
thyroid cancer dataset
we used that list of upregulated kinases
to find kinase inhibitors or drug
targets using the kinase mg database
as shown anaplastic lymphoma kinase
receptor or alk
was common in all groups
alk tyrosine kinase inhibitor
tae684 drug had was shown to have uh
angi tumor activity in four thyroid
cancer cell lines
during the current analysis we performed
micronee and rne sequencing analysis in
thyroid cancer tissue samples
based on our tcga analysis we identified
differentially expressed genes in
differentially expressed microorganisms
the enrichment showed that
germanogenesis process driving thyroid
cancer development was different in each
racial group
we also developed and validated the
diagnostic molecular tests of three
micrornas which seems to have better
accuracy in white and non-white
population
adding our markers as ancillary tests to
the current standard of care might have
a greater impact in improving
diagnostics in thyroid neutrals across
all racial groups
at this end i'm grateful that i was
working with the omics logic team
under the mentorship of doctors raghav
kor and ilya
i had the chance to explore and extract
meaningful insights from omix data that
will expand my career opportunities
please if you have any question
suggestion or feedback please reach out
to me through my email etoria at
tulane.edu
thank you